[Music]
hi guys I'm Greg Allah I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch from new rock stars
once upon a time in Hollywood new scenes
breakdown
we're just big new rock stars fans in
general I wanted to watch this video
especially because think Jam and Sony
have sent over to us a special box that
we are going to unbox after the reaction
because we have just joined the Rick
Dalton fan club
they're paying us thirty thousand
dollars to talk me I just watch that
latest Naraku is very cool very gonna
check out what's in this box
afterwards but I also thought to build
some excitement and anticipation for it
watch what I'm assuming new rock stars
also got with these guys or something
potentially linked you know maybe we are
fans together maybe this is finally our
G to collab it may be they're gonna
spoil everything that's in the box yes
or we're gonna be like now I'm really
excited to hear the story of Hollywood's
darkest night 3-fold is a bloody
tarantino fairytale wave all history
should have played out blu-ray DVD and
digital look the crap that made this
film so great the production design the
cinematography the costume design the
clothes I'm gonna break down all this
additional footage the cool details that
you might have overlooked and once upon
a time in Hollywood Wow I've seen it yes
and thank you to Sony Pictures respond
Serena's video Tony it was nice enough
to send me the different versions of
what the time whoa Wow some amazing
collectibles included I'm gonna get to
all of this all the additions you got to
break them all down
both of the DVD with the amazing film
and all the bonus material but if you're
a real fan collector a Tarantino we know
[Laughter]
oh my god I hope one of these DVDs will
be going up on my wall vinyl record got
two songs in the soundtrack you'll
notice how the art shows Rick Dalton's
appearance in the hullabaloo show which
brings us to our first additional theme
in which Rick sings Jim load read or
write a series in the 60s you look into
the lyrics of green door the song
actually reflects the rich situation in
this bill because of the amount of
singer who can't sleep because music
coming for a nearby Club so it goes over
pops on its green door but then gets
turned away from the private club Rick
similarly is the next door neighbor to
astray and outsider looking in at the
party and in this film is very tough the
Manson Family Rick finally gets admitted
into this private party with material
our commercials for old Chattanooga beer
which is drinks in this movie in
Tarantino's recurring in universe
cigarette label red apple is also a clip
from Rick's Western series bounty la
featuring Tarantino collaborator Michael
Madsen and the sheriff that episode is
sponsored by red apple and Twinkies
which also appear in the national scene
that I was most excited to see an
extended scene showing Charles Manson
continuing to look for Terry Melcher
after he scoped out the house with Jay
Sebring in it Terry Melcher was the
music producer in over in England the
lengthy tape house
Manson rambles on to a manager about
signing him he mentions his free
friendship with Dennis Wilson of Beach
Boys which actually do this car work
Manson and his women were kicked out of
the house Manson claims to have written
a Beach Boys song but the manager shoots
him away while his dog bandit links up
our key and perhaps shadowy there's a
lot of Manson scenes cut out through the
Twinkie truck that he was driving the
early sentence cliff watching him from
the roof Nicoli the shower he waves it
yeah that's the shot oh damn that's the
shot is a tween eternity vanities now
there are two more additional scenes to
check out both from a set in the new CBS
Western
yes sir that shot a trailer and with
Perry as the Lancer brothers as they
need to be young marry Bella the
director cranes in and complements a
girl scene Hayley Mills eat your heart
out and not to the child actors from the
rat trap now this director is filmmaker
played by Nicholas Hammond Wanamaker
what became a theater director known for
his restoration of the Globe Theatre in
London oh that can answer additional
scene is a one-take chat but we want to
make her in rick mounted the acting crap
pretty hilarious want to make her tells
rick about a new script that he's
writing called the executioner where you
don't know whether the lead character is
good or bad or an innocent bystander
until the very end
much like Rik and cliff in this film who
come off as innocent bystanders that
actually have a pivotal role in the fate
of history here now if you're a
collector you didn't know that this is
once upon a time in Hollywood blu-ray
release also includes gifts with
purchase offered at retail and Best Buy
you'll get a collectible steelbook and
it just brandy and then the target one
there's an enrolled bill magazine with
articles and already taught me and click
booth in Hollywood night Wow Tarantino
tonight no we're not mess around party
going I love that the film includes all
these ways to appreciate it because
really what made it so great is the
whole book in the design dream tina grew
up in hollywood in the 1670s
and the way that the film suddenly
revises hollywood history works so well
because of the two hours that preceded
the twist worked so hard to make us feel
that we were actually watching real
authentic history unfold exactly he's
included in the blu-ray release explore
greatly told me to put a busy production
designer Barbara link probably held me
up on traffic just to make this one
sister to get samples of Sharon Tate's
clothes and jewelry and how she
recreated a famous snakeskin trench coat
that she warded the Rosemary's Baby
premiere which we see murder Robbie
where
oh that were they were going don't scar
coordinators well know that that was a
real picture of her Easter eggs in the
but in the movie the car has no because
he's a stuntman instant drivers wouldn't
put hubcaps on the car and we used to
kind of like when Tarantino's Reservoir
Dogs as the hero car that cliff drives
Rick is really that's it or is a 1930s
mg Roadster which Tarantino selected
from the film model shop and for the
Manson Family car butchering Jefferson
actually tracked down the real car
driven by Tex Watson that night the
collector oh we're to let them use it
for the film but they felt it would be
too morbid to shoot the actors in the
actual car so they the car in the box
forget about the film and TV industry
all the movies that the characters
watching the movie needed to look like
movies did when you watch them back then
the featurette goes into one of
Tarantino's craziest shot someone that
cream of Rick's life relative specially
to the history of surance yeah that's I
mean are they going to oh yeah they're
yeah they must pay for timelines to set
up the precision of the way they collide
in the final act to change Hollywood
history with a fairy tale ending that it
deserved and it been full but relatively
non historic night now so that Tate and
the others could define their legacies
the way that they should have been able
to again quit eating solo burger
Hollywood Hills Ultra HD blu-ray DVD and
digital the critically praised
performances from Leonardo DiCaprio Brad
Pitt Margot Robbie and loaded with over
twenty minutes of additional scenes
an exclusive access to the set get your
copy today follow me on Twitter at
everything you love thanks for watching
bye dude dude you know I'm normally not
really a blu-ray collector one more I
remember there was a used to buy like
everything this weekend and now I only
really buy this stuff I truly love when
DVDs were first out I loved watching the
bonus features and then a guy like
little
crazy where there were like 120 hours of
- it's picturesque 4x4 disc you'll never
get through yeah I watch like deleted
scenes if they're online they release
them online for like I'm sure I'll check
it out or here now once upon time in
Hollywood this video made me go I want
to really look at all the behind the
scenes feature yeah they're supposed to
be a [ __ ] yeah I think you may just get
your wish things to the good people I
think Jana's Sony Home Entertainment
yeah in fact when we tear it up up okay
all right oh my god Wow 12 seconds later
up welcome welcome to the rick dalton
fan club dude that's what it says and
then if it lists everything that's gonna
be in this box and I don't want no all
right all right
oh damn oh there's that special well
which one is it it's the one with the
vinyl record I below my god really yeah
yeah special edition as I was watching
the new rock stars video on this I was
like I really hope one of these blue
races in there which of the various
traditions is it gonna be there's no
only the final I believe sylia oh my god
oh and there's even the little mat or
the Maddie oh damn this is the one we
gotta posters oh yeah lucky I heard
Chris Stockman talk about these this is
Rick Dalton in a Mad Magazine how funny
yeah this oh we got the poster up
letters yawn and I know my new this is
like a full-on collector's edition they
even have this here where it's like Rick
Dalton signed this it's for fans of Rick
Dalton of course well there's an actual
vinyl here yeah he showed it he pulled
it out like it was blue - oh yeah
cool and in the 4k Ultra HD version this
blu-ray the digital download the artwork
in here is incredibly no do you think
it's actual art or do they digitally
change it they change real photos of
them feel like knowing Tarantino
especially I feel like they probably
would have got a real movie poster
artists draw some of these up what yeah
look out Pouncy but now your blender
doesn't have to rot out in the open now
I got a lunch box yeah I'm keeping the
lunch box
I'm keeping the flask inside one bar
look look Rick Dalton fan membership
that's gotta go on the wall where no one
will be able to see it we can sign it
the real rejects Oh flask John is a
heavy alcoholic same drink right now
this is gonna come in handy I'm not as
think as you drunk I am here you go
Thanks and it's even got Rick Dalton's
signature on it so I can think of him
beating himself up in his trailer while
I chug down rum okay but now we got to
go to the store and get the other 18
different versions of the blue we need a
standard edition we need to get the
standard DVD edition is is so awesome
yeah oh man thank you guys look and we
even made out better than Eric Foss did
because he didn't get this lunch box I'm
actually glad we watched the new rock
stars video first because it would have
been a part of me going a lot of the
video oh I get it
but this bad new lunchbox is probably my
favorite one yes because that's like
super in the know yeah you would have to
definitely have seen once upon a time
hello would it be like oh I love those
are my favorite kind of collectible
fruit you really got to be
well made to hear John look I'll keep
the DVD and here you just put this in
your pocket take the record home with
you okay buddy tuck this right on in and
there we go
don't come back out there is it that's
how we take care of our property very
limited edition things alright guys well
once upon a time in Hollywood is now out
on a whole bunch of different versions
of the blu-ray yes so make sure to go
get yourself a copy once a ton time
Hollywood today and what new rock stars
I report about the deleted scenes maybe
wonder specifically goes with
Tarantino's film being so damn long as
it is and the possibility of him doing
you know what he did for hateful eight
where he cut it up into a miniseries
yeah I made an extended version and then
put it up into four different episodes
yeah if you would do that once the fun
time in Hollywood including this footage
and just thinking about what they did
with because it seemed like Manson was a
much bigger presence in the original cut
that's the sense I got I was like most
of what I'm hearing stuff has been cut
out
it was interesting especially because
this project started out in the public
eye as being it's his Manson movie and
very much wasn't that in a no I ready no
everything is a cameo yeah from the guy
who did it on mine hunter it's weird
because that guy did two completely
different versions of Mara Marilyn
Manson he portrayed the wrong guy he had
to get it right this time and it was
upon Simon showed up on set with a grill
no ribs he plays a much younger version
pre Manson murders in Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood which seems like a much
more like charming guy and then a mine
hunter he plays the incarcerated
long-bearded Looney version Marilyn
Manson and went to completely dead with
a curse it's his fault man don't worry
he'll do Marilyn Manson I'm sure about
the first person to confused
and pull pieces of work up from two
different treat of heads so it's
interesting without already know that
actors name just no impress a guy who
prefer ever played Charles Manson yeah
so major credit to that guy and I also
find it interesting how both once upon a
time in Hollywood and the Irishman came
out this year and they're both kind of
this strange
could almost feel like a culmination
film that deals with parts of history
that one is definitely fictitious and
another one is possibly fictitious yeah
and they both have a main female
character who doesn't really talk in the
films that just hit my head while I was
watching this video who's this silent
woman in the Irishman and a pack and a
pack we know I forgot she was even in
that it's been all the talk on Twitter
Martin Scorsese hates women
oh yeah and women mmm alright guys well
make sure to subscribe to new rock stars
as soon as you can make sure to
subscribe to the real rejects click our
notification bell once upon a time in
Hollywood is out on blu-ray right now
we'll catch you guys soon
woo and get yourself a pack of red apple
today for Tarantino recut this movie
again